let's find out more about the impact of
rising inflation and the increasing cost
of living nz standing by for us in
manchester this morning uh high in z uh
inflation even higher than expected
yeah a 30-year high k and a lot of
people will be looking at that and
thinking
how on earth are we expected to afford
very basic things we know the cost of
living crisis
has been worsening and today it takes
yet another hit this
new announcement today
takes into account the month of uh a war
in ukraine it takes into account fuel
prices food prices going up as well and
really paints a bleak picture of the
future in terms of finances for everyday
people and we're in uh manchester's uh
smithfield market and we've got uh
mariella with us uh here who owns this
uh very it's not too fishy actually a
fish stall here
fish doesn't smell well there we go
mariela just give us your reaction to
hearing the news this morning that
inflation has hit a 30-year high well
i'm not surprised at all it's been
increasing since the beginning of brexit
and we've been we've had whammy with
brexit we've had coveted and now we are
suffering this terrible um injustice of
the russian war um all our costs since
just pre-brexit have been steadily
rising and i would say that
the import costs on the fish from abroad
at least 25 to 30 percent we sell a lot
of poultry which is based in this
country and penrith our main poultry
supplier and his costs have gone up
because of course they've stopped the
farmers using the red diesel
there's been bird flu the cost of
delivering from henrietta to here every
day is costing him another 250 to 350
pound just for the increase in diesel
and so when we talk about the cost of
living crisis people coming here you
know want to buy fish for their business
for personal use and things like what
are people telling you when you're
having to put your prices up as well as
a result we've tried as much as we
possibly can to swallow as much
of that but we just can't it's an
impossibility um when you're every
delivery is costing you an extra
20
we don't make that we're wholesalers and
the when we retail out we don't put a
massive profit on you know it's 10 it's
15 and these are people that are
struggling these people that can the
reason they're here is because for
between 15 and 20 pounds they can fill
their freezer of good
quality item
and they're every time we import this
stuff because it comes across the sea
well the container prices have gone up
by five times so they've gone from three
and a half thousand to fourteen thousand
this is a knock-on situation
so they've got to contend with the the
gas and the electricity the food prices
going up travel going up
what are they supposed to choose do we
eat or do we eat
and it's disgraceful yeah it's a it's a
very tough question for for a lot of
people across the country now marilyn
thank you so much just painting a
picture there of what it's like for her
as a business but also for the customers
that come and shop here now the bank of
england have also said that the
inflation could increase later this year
to
a 40-year high later on this year to 10
now that really would be an even bleaker
picture for many across the country but
today's news already many will be
looking and thinking uh whether they do
eat or or heat and that is a big
question for many across the country
okay um indeed thanks very much thank
you